[Music]
a few days before continuing my journey
from india to iran
i went to a company of trade ships in
the british raj's office i asked for a
fine room in the ship
and the head of the company said choose
whatever room you want
except for you there's no other sailor
in first class
some days after coming to the ship i
realized i was indeed the only traveller
on this ship
and i could go anywhere i wanted nobody
wanted to travel on the oman sea
and besides there was no one that could
accept the danger of travelling in this
season
on the persian gulf even the true
sailors can barely protect themselves
against such waves
there are a bunch of flies in the ship's
rooms too which annoy everyone on the
ship
the weather is constantly wet and i'm
struggling to barely breathe
the ship's name is ashore
on the 20th of january our ship left
muscat
and despite the pleasing and peaceful
atmosphere of the night
the heat was still galling at midnight
the thermometer was still showing
39 degrees but long last we passed
through the hormos strait
the persian gulf is a historical sea
i remembered that in 325 bc
niacious alexander's admiral sailed from
the mouth of the sinned to the mouth of
the tigris
after this the greeks and romans and
iranians fought against people of barsu
for ownership of the sea after that the
arabs and the portuguese fought
after that dutch but victory was for
britain
the english men in the early 19th
century and they cleared this sea from
the omani pirates
on the 24th of january we arrived to
boucher
the coastal city of boucher now is in
chaos
the iranian government tried with the
help of the englishmen to implement
strict lockdown regulations
but the people closed the bazaar and in
mosques
gathered to rebel
in these kind of journeys people can see
special phenomena which are specific
to certain lands i read before about
this in books but now i'm seeing it with
my own eyes
there was water of a lake in the
distance so calm
and i could clearly see trees i looked
on the map of iran but there wasn't any
lake in that place
so i asked my servant and he answered
there is no lake
that was a mirage
there is a problem with the soldiers in
shiraz not only the riflemen are not
reliable or responsible and cannot
protect anyone
but they regularly ask for gratuity with
such behavior and lack of discipline
i can't use the venerable word soldier
for them
i think nobility responsibility loyalty
to the emperor patriotism gratitude to
serve the country
lack of corruption and ignoring wealth
are virtues which make
japanese soldiers and gunners different
from other countries
one of the most incredible things in
iran is the shu
which is comfortable and durable at the
same time
there are layers in place of toes and
the heel of the shoe is sewn
and then there is a hard insole under it
they call
give the japanese shoe is made of cotton
and in a five-day journey such as this
one
would be destroyed easily
[Music]
there are two ways to travel in iran
caravan
and chaparr on a caravan journey the
traveller has a tent bed and
the other things necessary for travel so
a caravan is significantly easier
and comfortable in comparison to the
chaparra but a traveler has to spend
more money
and time to travel travellers by caravan
can wait and
stay wherever they want for example
along a river and give water to horses
or freely stand upon persepolis
and passer guard to imagine the royal
and noble lives of the great heroes of
history
such as kurosh daryush and
kashaya shah this is the travel way
of a daimyo
on the other hand there is the chapa or
speedy
which i chose this way of travel is hard
and painful just like hikiaku men
on the 20th of august we arrived at a
hillside
and finally could see persepolis
the site was small the columns were like
wooden flag sticks
in local matsuris the column heads of
the halls
stair carvings cornices freezes tombs of
the emperors
no description of such majesty could do
no justice to it
this was the remains of a grand palace
that held the destructive thunder of
alexander
eventually we turned right and saw in
the distance a little
fuji between four other mountains during
this entire trip i saw
nothing natural to compare to the glory
of damavand
that seemed like a second fuji
the sun was setting and the sky was in
twilight
seeing this view in the vast plain was
unbelievable
why didn't i bring my camera
izadcast is one of the strangest places
in the world that people live
the town is on a lone mountain in the
heart of a plane
there is only one way to the town the
muddy houses have
floors and it seems that they're all in
one stronghold
it's like the hanging gardens of babylon
[Music]
on the 14th of september i met atabag
azam amin al-sultan
his imperial highness gladly and
hopefully wished for friendly trade
between our two sublime countries and
subjects
he asked how was the general fukushima
yasumasa
who met him three years ago the power of
the
shah is absolute and he is the owner of
all life and wealth
he is the main statesman of iran and if
i remember correctly he is 47.
how young to be dealing with all the
politics and administer the realm
though his hair was white he appeared a
wise and reasonable man but his
body was weak and tired the great
ambassador of britain
said the shah doesn't really rule at all
the real law
is religious law and the true power is
with the imams
the people of iran do not let foreigners
see their way of life and family
traditions
i only saw half of the people of iran
upper and lower class women cannot meet
with strangers
i heard by the law men can have four
wives and over
and that it depends how wealthy they are
if they can have unofficial and
temporary wives wives are always in the
house with the husbands and can only
speak with female guests
i wonder how iranian women pass their
time and what is their joy in life
iranian food is delicious the main foods
are made from meat
bread vegetable and fruit and recently
they started drinking whiskey
and champagne along with beer which is
deemed a
symbol of modernism they love to hunt
ride and shoot
in recent years people have travelled
from tehran to kasvin
by and there aren't chaparras anymore
so inevitably despite how expensive it
was i chose toroshke
because i had to to arrive in asia minor
we rode day and night because the horse
wasn't a great walker
and multiple times the rider waited and
whipped the horse or
pushed the doroshke to force the poor
horse to move
the road was even worse than the road to
tehran and it didn't even have
one natural wonder recently a private
russian transport company made a new
road for the duroshk
which is still under construction and it
seems there was a collusion between the
two
because i was in a hurry i ended up
paying double at least
i stayed in the hotel kazvin which
belongs to the cosby government
when i awoke the next morning i saw a
rusty old doroshke
but i didn't complain yet after just two
british miles the
roche k broke it was the first time i
saw a vehicle in iran break
the rider went back to kazvin to fetch
another doroshke
so i sent my servant with him and stayed
in the road alone with all my
possessions
the dust blew in my eyes and the sun was
shining in the clear blue
sky passing travellers who saw me on the
road
a foreigner alone with all my things
laughed
and humiliated me and the new doroske
wasn't any good either
it was like the entire carriage between
kiyobashi road to asukasa
every minute on it was agony
[Music]
according to the travel contract i
should pay after arriving at rasht
but the rider stopped before the albors
mountains
and said he wanted his money now and
more
well i'm sure my servant would have
protected me but the heat was growing
and the rider had a gun with him so i
agreed
again in the mist on the mountains one
of the horses with all of my clothes and
some other stuff was lost
but after that the road was glorious and
lovely
and the further we went the greener it
became
there was a steamship in the anzali port
and on the other
side were the persian realms of the
russian empire
and after that i'll finally arrive at
the ottoman empire
my time in iran had been a test of my
patience
both physically and mentally and
immediately
i fell fast asleep on the deck like a
dead man
you